a good Popoff is like the icing on the
cake of a super tight mega hype victory
nothing is quite as infectious as the
joy of a fighting game player jumping up
and down while hurling insults at the
guy he just bodied so in honor of this
very noble tradition here are our picks
for the top 10 best pop offs in fgc and
smash history some of the best pop off
happen when a player smashes their
opponents so badly but all they want to
do is rub it in their face as deeply as
possible and so kicking off our list is
axes vicious pop up after for stalking
silent walls in less than a minute at
evil 2014 nice slideshow not even trying
to get shield staff as the shields do
get really small other stock big gotcha
pika-pika the picture champ is humongous
here oh oh man
silent wolf we've seen a lot of force
sucks on this stage before but 35
seconds saw will be down to his last
stop is he gonna get it before minute
passes whoa let's see he's right to the
edge oh my god that was emphatic that
was amazing
pop offs don't always have to come after
a match no no in fact a sick pop on can
set the stage for the most epic of games
while our pick for number 9 is
technically a pop on boom goes pregame
antics against Daigo Umehara at evil
2011 are just so good we had to include
them
[Applause]
after all that not only did Foucault win
he to old I go without dropping around
and topped it off with the perfect
[Applause]
at number eight we have a Popoff of
infamous proportions that's right
it's Moshe gays premature celebration at
evil 2015 so smart he couldn't burst
because of the super
[Applause]
[Applause]
was over and take it flex Donna
unbelievable taking center stage at
number seven is the monumental rivalry
between two of the gods of melee armada
and hungrybox specifically armadas
Popoff following the intense grand
finals at the slash summit to an ice pop
off together at unison our mata has had
some sweet pop ups but this one is just
too good sometimes you can't be held
responsible for what your body does when
the hype takes over coming in at number
six is Justin Wong's barrel roll from
evil 2014 Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3
grand finals testimony gonna return to
this throw I think we're gonna see it
double turn hold on the king I'm not
even an actor yet
I'm beautiful piece can you blame him
he not only reclaimed his throne atop
NBC but beat all his demons along the
way that calls for a little celebration
if your ears are sensitive mute this
video for the next 90 seconds because at
number 5 the potty mouth is are coming
out street fighter streamer low-tier God
is well known for his trash talk however
in 2014 he chose to start a feud with
vist cans which ultimately led to LTG
getting his just desserts a grudge match
season 4 why would we shake hands
we do not shake hands at quartz ranches
Wow and if that wasn't enough this camp
laid into LTG in the post match
interview absolutely destroying him body
and soul let me let me tell you why I
got so mad what I do in my spare time I
volunteer with father Joe so what that
is in San Diego that's a homeless
outreach I help people get off of drugs
so you saying that all I do is play
video games you saying that I'm on meth
that I do drugs no seriously [ __ ] them
there's gonna come a point when you
forget about what happened and you're
gonna want to come back at me and you're
gonna want to watch the taste of my dick
out of your mouth
[Applause]
one thing is that on Twitter that was
right that was right I am too old to be
playing with the child so what what I
want you to do what I want you to do is
go back to the McDonald's that you work
at ask your boss to give you some
overtime and then and then come back and
play me for more money because this was
kid stuff if that's not a savage Popoff
we don't know what is
they say artists suffer for their art
and so it's only fitting that hungry
boxes masterpiece of both hype and pain
takes number four on the list
wait holy cow that was winners - oh my
god he's gonna break the TV good pop
mama this is with Popoff box is that you
know what this to be honest I understand
why right now he was holding it's okay
dude yes it's not often we see a Popoff
so intense it causes physical injury and
so when we do it's earned a spot on this
list sometimes a good Popoff needs a
little extra spice and so on number
three we have infiltrations Popoff after
winning evolution 2016
while his pose as he basket in the
cheers of the crowd is now iconic it's
what came next that took this moment
from famous to one of the best pop ups
of all time
download complete Tokyo has never had
the same sort of pokerface his fellow
Japanese fighting game God Daigo has and
at number two he shows just what can
happen when he lets the hype flow free
so kudos gets up and walks off perfectly
[Applause]
good taking the top spot on the list is
a wile reso dramatic it has led to not
just one but two world-class Popoff's
the extremely personal rivalry between
pay brad and wolf chrome has become the
stuff of fgc legend what is happening
out it's gonna take it oh boy wolf car
but it was que brad at final round
twenty who took it to the next level let
him tell her my buddy self talk to him
tell him about yourself yourself
suggestion I like to see the crowds
absolutely wild as k-rod leans into
Wolfe Chrome's face pretty well sums it
up
this is disrespect of an always cosmic
degree I love it
Wow amazing I love it Popov don't get
better than this did you see what he did
and those were our picks for the top 10
best pop off in fcc and smash history
but before we're done we couldn't leave
out what is quite possibly the best
non-pro Popoff in history so in our very
first honorable mention enjoy Stevie H
being Steve H
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]